got a king player absolutely
i've i've wanted this so bad i love king
plays on top eight
really just excited three gig i mean i'm
excited to see lmg mob this is the guy
the evo online eu east champion you know
the person who
everyone else in that top four he was
the guy to put them in to lose he
defeated every single one to move
forward so
um i said before even i was the person i
was seeing evo online eve i was seeking
people strong and we didn't see strong
compete in that so for me that was me
saying okay if strogan said he could
have won but lmg more beat strong today
put stroke into the loser's breakfast so
let's see but her greetings you know
rocking that king i know you're excited
wave dashing with king straight away
instant uh shiny wizard i'm liking what
i'm seeing straight away back to four um
yeah this this is looking like a strong
king already nice bat one two nice stuck
in punish there from mob we're not going
to break the water he's going for the
fancy stuff oh
yay oh but the hot hopknee
this could be the route no comp no
balcony that wasn't oh wait would this
work he's gonna be airborne oh he did
what
that was a punish
that was absolutely crazy
i was gonna say he was unfortunate
enough to get that wall break but then
it all worked out pretty well for him
yeah and that that gap three was
actually your punish on the rage jazz
and great block uh great throw break
there from uh nmg mob he needed that
nice sport for neutral
oh too a duck
oh bad punisher as well the ford water
option is that very nice try to go for a
quran it doesn't work out
always go for the mix up there that's
what i like about mob doesn't always go
for max damage but catches mob ducking
what's the follow-up the alley kicks
greetings with a great start right now
look at the way i love it
did it back two in the previous round
then went for a two-throw after he got
ducked and launched for it at that time
he he mixed it up the last music has
started the final round last music has
started when you pick this outfit here
we go down back four count here is
powering up this is it he needs the
music gonna do some fancy stuff here
whilst anyone nice block and punishment
nice
cancel it new slash
very nice there from mob we should be
going to the wall yes we are shoulder
can he take this round with the music
power up oh no downpours you can hit it
unfortunately
he's a side step yeah this isn't good
this isn't dead this is it it is it is
that
what a start there from greetings to i
know i know you love that talk about
talk to people what you saw there
i i'm really happy with what i saw like
there were there were a bunch of things
in there that i loved good punishment on
the minus their team uh move and
a memory of what the opponent did
straight after some previous moves so
when he did that back one two went into
the two break got launched with a while
standing one he said okay i remember
what he did last time this time i'm
gonna go for a forward three just frame
and there was lots of tough technical
stuff that he was doing in there um that
i was really surprised with i mean
that's not a pocket king that's a fully
developed rounded king and it's looking
very strong
yeah definitely the perfect start there
against someone like mob as well and
people probably looking at mob as the
the name to take i thought this is the
thing uh when you win a huge tournament
in the the same way that mob did you put
a target on your back
people are gonna start looking at you
people are gonna take you up people are
going to watch that game back like okay
this is what he does i'm be ready for it
and just like that we saw greetings was
ready for it you know he went for the
interesting combo enders uh into some
setups the first time it worked next
time i didn't try it again didn't work
you know like mob is
he's being counter played here to you
right now so it's up to him to to sort
of that's the thing when you're in in
position in his position right like um
when you're at the top it's gonna see
you can't look down and see everyone you
know like these guys they you are so
highly visible everyone's watching your
game everyone you play you don't get to
see everyone play don't see what they do
especially with a character like king
can be very scary but i like this choice
here mumpo's elected to go for the
infinite stage
yeah i've noticed that he likes the
infinite stage which is kind of unusual
for a lot last player he doesn't just
pick it against king i've noticed he's
done that in other games but this is
definitely the right choice especially
in the context of that previous match
king got a lot of wall damage
come visit arctic snowfall
we've got great weather
in the holiday
uh
what do you call it holiday brochures
okay but oh great
they're on the down back for greetings
looking so good right now
about three
about four
two one
interesting choice there
very tentative start from both players
well not the best we're punished there
treasure almost doesn't work out nice
break on the regular throw half the
round is gone
oh nice
can go for the fourth floor neutral two
slow starts up board two nice punish
there from greetings
oh great low parry again on the down one
powerbomb wants to follow up here
just stays down the wire
four greetings four rounds straight over
the evo ears champion
looking very strong indeed press is
there though
he needs this this is a great start now
from mob he needs some momentum
running three last frames nice break on
the throw
right is it again doesn't work out two
well down four two doesn't commit to the
second hit
oh
crash dash while standing one plus two
very nice
he's a little bit worried about oaky i
think he's worried about you going for
something big and just getting
completely lightning screwed into this
into oblivion but i like it
i will
and potentially the round is he going to
regret that he could
race drive spent down board one
okay what patience
no oh my days he's got him
what is going on in our winner's
semi-finals
gets good oaky after this onions
is in serious trouble right now again
the crowd at one plus two what's the
okay
oh he's got him
not like this greetings takes it six
rounds straight over mob the eu east
champion that is
that is the biggest upset of the day i